i dj'd so i was like 24 25 and then uh i
went to a knife fight without a knife
and i end up looking like this and they
put holes in me
how how close were you to death dead
deal kindly got me to the hospital i was
i'd bled out how many times did they
stab you
i guess
i'll leave that for my memoirs those
those little beautiful details
for your memoirs
but you had no idea that these they just
attacked you no i i i yeah yeah your
mouth on them no they they told me
they'd [ __ ] up my brother
we've done your brother was the comment
and that in glasgow means he's done he's
he's over and i lost my [ __ ]
and i slapped some [ __ ] and i said
i'll take all you guys outside and i
went outside like
and i waited for them like a [ __ ]
idiot and i knew they they were sold up
but anyway they come with those fire
eggs and i went
and then
fire spy yourself by myself with my
trusty heineken bottle which was not
very handy jesus christ
stop stop stop
and you did you honestly when you close
your eyes i'm dead now this is my end of
my life i was so enraged i remember that
but i remember the pain of the knife
going in if that hurt you could feel you
weren't in shock it hurts
just you your body just buckles
and you just feel out everything coming
out you
and then he tried to stab me twice and i
grabbed the blade and it cut through my
there all the way through here
i'm punching it in my thumb
so and then the other guy was
yeah it was just ripped anyway i got my
back against the wall kept kicking and
then um i started walking
and then anyway i i survived they got me
the hard work they survived the slogan
goes on and on right but they got me
there
and then like italian whatever brought
me back to life and then uh
bobby
when i go to hospital bobby came to see
me and he said tommy
why
why keep doing this what crazy world
you're in why don't you try
joining my theater company
come and join rain how old are you 25
just 25.
and then i'd never thought about acting
in my life not for one second i'd always
loved movies you know what i mean what
did you love what
what inspired you what did you who what
actor did you know the most bizarre
thing was was uh was mad max
with mel mel gibson mad max
mad max was a badass it was a badass
[ __ ] and then
my first movie is braveheart with mel
gibson it was one of those bizarre ones
so i did theater with bobby for a couple
of years
braveheart comes to town
patsy pollock casting director sees a
little bit of meow she comes to the
theater goes
get right have them wrapped and clean
and sprout round some hell tomorrow so i
go and see mel and the rest is um
join us every week as we discuss all
that is smallville we're gonna watch
every episode that's right with you
talkville the ultimate smallville
podcast we're gonna go way back join tom
welling and michael rosenbaum every week
as they rewind every episode of
smallville and discuss their experiences
with friends fans and co-stars tockville
the ultimate smallville podcast